right well it's now been one week since
russian energy company gas prompt
drastically reduced gas deliveries
through its north stream pipeline to
germany to just 20 percent of its normal
flow russia says maintenance issues and
western sanctions are preventing it from
pumping more gas but germany's
chancellor olaf schultz today accused
russia of blocking the delivery of a
turbine destined for the pipeline the
turbine is now in germany after being
repaired in canada
inspecting the giant turbine schultz
said it was working and ready to use
once russia requested it
schultz said russia's claims of
technical problems were not credible and
said gas customers should expect more
restrictions
we need to understand that it is not
enough to do everything right
in this difficult situation related to
russia's war in ukraine
we must be clear that there can always
be a pretext that leads to something not
working
technical reasons have allegedly also
impacted gas exports to other european
countries
there too they were also
incomprehensible
all right well for more on this let's
bring in dw's political correspondent
emmanuel shaz manuel good to see you
should we consider chancellor schultz's
visit to this turbine
a big statement from him
it is a big statement and above all
pablo it shows you just how important
this matter is not only at a german
level but
the international dimension of this you
know this turbine being put back in
service or not this turbine in fact is
working just fine there's no reason why
it shouldn't be transported that was the
message from the chancellor so that was
quite clear and the delays don't come
from the german side that's what olasha
said that there's no government decision
that makes the transport of this turbine
impossible nor is there any technical
issue on siemens's side no technical
reasons uh whatsoever that is what allah
shows said so the chancellor does blame
russia for any delay incurring and he
insisted that the truth and facts were
important at a moment where we witnessed
a war that triggered this energy crisis
but a war that is not just happening on
the ukrainian front line but it is that
is also a very much a global economic
conflict at this stage
now the chancellor also announced a
series of measures that deal directly
with the energy crisis what more can you
tell us on those
he did indeed aside from what we already
knew for example the efforts that must
be made by industries companies and the
population to save up as much energy as
possible before the winter all of
schultz also mentioned the importance of
filling up the gas reserves
and announce more aid packages for those
who need it the most for example mostly
financial support for low income
families he talked about 30
billion euros that will be used to that
effect
thank you emmanuel dw's political
correspondent emmanuel shaz